[Musique]
le gel fixe à fort en résiste à tout les
éléments air feu eau et terre très bien
bien jouer mozart
gérard vous avez quoi alors moi pour
cette campagne j'ai pensé une pub dans
laquelle on aurait un adolescent
traversant la rue il se fait percuter
par un camion l'adolescent est indemne
le camion est complètement détruit
pourquoi parce qu'il a percuté la coupe
de cheveux de l'adolescent gel fixe à
fort ok pas mal du tout je note c'est
efficace didier vous avez quoi c'est
avoue didier c'est avoue didier c'est
avoue didier vous écoute
euh oui je suis parti du principe que
les consommateurs de gel sont
majoritairement des des adolescents des
adolescents est ce que font généralement
les adolescents c'est qu'ils jouent aux
jeux vidéo
il écoute beaucoup de musique il les
écoute beaucoup de musique
et donc comme il écoute beaucoup de
musique bat fans de leur chanteur
tout à fait et donc en prenant en
considération tous ces éléments
qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir dans notre
campagne de pub leur chanteur préféré
je serai quoi faire une jeune fille que
sa forme exactement c'est ça c'était
l'idée que j'avais
ok très bonne idée une idée est simple
efficace exactement ce qu'il nous faut
pour la campagne bon on est bon pour
ceux brief alors ensuite on a quoi
pensez la forme de la nouvelle bouteille
de gels douche sanex didier vous avez
l'air en forme on va commencer par vous
alors quelles sont les formes de savon
qui existe sur le marché les bouteilles
de gel douche transparence oui les blocs
de savon traditionnel c'est ça et c'est
tout et c'est tout et donc comment est
ce qu'on pourra apporter quelque chose
de nouveau une bouteille de gel douche
en forme de blocs de salon traditionnel
bingo les mixtapes mais c'est super ça
comme des idiots et les autres prenez
exemple sur didier j'avais justement
gérard je pense que là on n'aura pas
plus que ce bref là donc vous fatiguez
pas alors l'utilitaire renault habile
gérard vos écoutes non ans didier tout
simple alors pour ça j'ai pensé un petit
truc dont je suis un peu fier aux
éléments qui est public est ternie
[Musique]
attendait didier ce genou depuis le
début puisque vous raconter gérard c'est
nous qui faisons au boulot aucune des
idées de vient de lui didier ce qu'il
dit la vérité
j'ai raison n'est ce pas montre nous ton
travail
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ton petit
ordinateur là alors c'est bien ce que je
pensais que dalle dans ce cas je vais
être grand prince je vais me permettre
de te montrer la porte
by didier
à la revoyure alors là c'est très
intéressant ce qui se passe regardez
bien gérard et dites moi qu'est ce que
vous ressentez chez lui une sorte de
nervosité ouais une sorte de frustration
presque la jalousie de la jalousie
pas du tout et pourquoi ça parce qu'il a
de moins bonnes idées que nous c'est ça
parce que c'est un looser comme on en a
rarement vu ça c'est faux et on devrait
le licencier a carrément pour faute
grave comme ça il n'aurait pas
d'indemnités vous savez quoi je le vire
on admire légère
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors quand on a aimé cette vidéo etc on
est sûr de pas vouloir rater les
prochaines qu'il faut cliquer sur le
macaron multiprise pour sable sao paulo
non pour sable salsa à la danse non pour
sarsat teulet sabrina lopez avec moi au
collège des entraîneurs pour sa bonne
bonne année